Continental Tire coaches corner
Continental Tire the official tire Major
League Soccer soccer fans expect peak
performance on the pitch also demand
peak performance on the street
that's why Continental has built a tire
for what you do whether you're heading
to the game taking the kids to practice
or just kicking it around Continental
it's engineered a line of tires that
includes best-in-class wet braking
superb handling
it's the best tire you can get officials
supported the Dan Patrick show visit
Continental Tire calm to learn more he's
the head coach of the USC Trojans went
ten and three last year clay Helton
joining us he Continental Tire Coaches
Corner House morale coach doing well do
a little well practice eight today full
pads so right in the heart of camp right
now most famous quarterback in Los
Angeles's who oh my goodness I would
have to say I like ours a lot right he's
pretty popular after coming off a good
season I think there's probably he's the
one that may have the most expectations
on them as of right now so a promising
young prospect is playing some really
good football and hopefully would
continue this season I know you want him
to continue this progress here but I how
often do you caution people on hey he's
young let him develop because we we've
already got him as the number one pick
in the draft you know and Sam Donald
certainly showed promise last year but
what's your role in this with the media
and the expectations on him yeah
definitely I mean there's always
expectations when the quarterback a USC
and we accept that they we know that and
you know if you don't like it don't
accept the job and he welcomes it he
doesn't see it as an obligation he sees
it as an opportunity but we also got to
be realistic
as he and I both know you know he's only
started nine games and his ceiling is so
high and he has not reached it and
there's so much left to do so you know
we're focusing on capturing the now
capturing this moment trying to get
better today trying to create a big
stack of little wins don't worry about
what's going to happen five six seven
eight months from now
and I'm fortunate as a head coach
because he's a kid that truly believes
in the team's success rather than his
own success and that's what he's
concerned with and and he understands he
know as he says coach I'm not a finished
product I've got so much more I can do
to be able to grow and that's what we
try to do on a day-to-day basis
you also look at his demeanor if you
don't win and you have that demeanor
then we're very critical of you like Jay
Cutler but then you have Joe Montana who
had a very cool calm demeanor Sam has a
very calm you know it's almost like his
EKG there's no move movement - is his
heart rate there is that just who he is
I mean and how is that a positive for
him yeah you know he is so special in
his mental toughness because you look at
him and you say gosh take me remind you
of that great picture or that great
golfer you know that guy the guy that
takes that one swing or that one pitch
and once he swings it that's gone that
swings gone that pitch is gone and he
moves on and it doesn't matter whether
it was good or bad he just moves on to
the next step when my favorite plays of
the entire season last year is that last
pass he threw in the Rose Bowl to tie to
tie the game up and every
eighteen-year-old is supposed to be
going nuts in that scenario and just
going crazy and he literally Sue's he
completes it looks over to the sidelines
at me and goes coach are we going for
one or two explain that I'm like gosh my
body what an old soul with a mature soul
and thank God he's a Trojan because he's
helping us a lot how do you explain that
game that last game he didn't see that
how would you explain what happened in
that game - from addy just it was really
neat because it was two really good
football teams at the time playing their
best football you know Penn State and
USC were playing as good a football as
er was out there and competing at such a
high level and it made for a great show
I've been this is going to be my 23rd
year of college football and that was
the most fun I've ever had in a game
I've seen James Franklin them several
times since that game and we always
each other about and wasn't that
specially goes yeah you sorry doc but he
but he said yeah it's what unbelievable
special game for college football our
fans and and it really shows where those
are two programs are at right now and
hopefully headed back in the right
direction so I'm going to clay Helton
USC head football coach what do your
kids your wife did what if they have
UCLA colors accidentally like bluish or
gold is anybody what happens if that
have you know you're around them you
know accidentally not a lot of blue in
our house okay
especially light blue okay all right
probably about a lot of Cardinal of gold
over a mission side of the street either
but you know we're fortunate here I mean
it's a unique rivalry because you really
you know you see those rivalries are
usually in different towns and you have
two elite academic schools elite
athletic schools in the same city right
across the street from each other makes
for a lot of fun if you arm wrestled Jim
Mora who wins uh he probably gets his
big dude he got I would get Pete my butt
off but Jim pretty good in shape and a
big man so it'd be a heck of a fight but
Jim may get me but you're not conceding
right
no never I never hang can fight on right
I'm slide on every step of the way yes
sir a lot of times and I mentioned this
last hour when you have a great
quarterback or you're coming off a you
know great end to a season and people
say oh can you carry that momentum over
and I always say you got to got to slow
your expectations and I really believe
that with you guys I don't I don't
consider you guys the best team in the
pac-12 doesn't mean you won't be but I
think sometimes you look and and the
expectations are maybe a little too high
for you guys I don't know talk me into
it that have I underestimated USC to
this point or do you agree that maybe
you know people are expecting too much
right now
yeah Dan I think what people see is they
say great quarterback they see Ronald
Jones being here but this team is
different than last year's - you know
you look at that Rose Bowl team there
were fourteen men that signed NFL
contracts and last year's team five were
drafted nine free agent contracts and
not only were they great players but
they were also great leaders and now
we've got some you know young players
trying to come up in that leadership
role you know uh camp Smith replacing of
Mike Hutchings as kind of a quarterback
of our defense Sam Darland in his third
season now trying to capture an entire
offense a 1000 so and Porter Gus and
trying to take over where Steve ET was
that as the rock of our defensive front
so there are some lessons that we learn
we got a lot of confidence out of last
year we learned a lot of lessons from
last season with our older guys but this
is a group that's going to have to grow
together because their their roles are
different you know they're in new
leadership roles guys that haven't
played like that young talented white
out core you know they're going to be
seeing bullets fired for the first time
in early September so and we'll go
through some growing pains there it's a
different team it's a talented team but
it's a different team than last year
best college football player you ever
coached against oh my goodness or played
against I would I tell you what I would
have to say over 23 years I know well I
know one is right here in the office
that is near and dear to my heart there
was a guy named T Martin badly right
right anger pretty good yeah pretty
broke played right after a pretty good
quarterback himself you came in and won
a national championship and I remember
being with dad and having to see and get
into CP and expectations that were on
him and and him leading that team to
national championship so I've always
respected T as a person and a coach but
I always go back and say well he was a
really really good great college
football player does he remind you how
often is he remind you that you won a
national championship uh
never never brings it up not one time
maybe one of those humble people I've
ever been around
this is where we know like a national
champion oh no net never wears it never
never wears it he's a he's about as good
as he is as a coach and as a player he's
a he's a pretty humble person do these
kids on the team know what he did in
college uh we mind him he won't remind
them but I do
anytime you win a national championship
at Tennessee as the quarterback that's
kind of instant respect so I usually do
that for him
well good luck this upcoming season
we'll check in with you when the season
starts but thanks again coach good to
talk to you again
then great talking to you thank you all
right let's clay Helton u.s. we had
football coach the Continental Tire
coaches corner they got a tire for you
we love being a partner they're a proud
supporter of the Dan Patrick show
Continental Tire the official tire of
Major League Soccer and soccer fans what
they expect they demand just like you
there is a tire for you they've
engineered a line of tires that includes
best-in-class wet braking superb
handling Continental Tire proud
supporter of the Dan Patrick show visit
Continental Tire calm for more the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience